[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce set
8 sport sur tv 60,18 l'émission ne pas
manquer si vous êtes un passionné de
sport local c'est parti pour le sommaire
de ce magazine foot us après deux ans de
crise sanitaire les templiers
d'elancourt ont enfin pu rejouer ce
samedi et ils ont remporté la victoire
face aux dragons de paris le résumé du
match dans ce magazine automobile 7 il
ya 20 ans 2002 l'équipe de formule 1
prost gp est basé à guyancourt et mise
en liquidation judiciaire coup de
projecteur sur cette écurie dirigé de
1997 à 2001 par alain prost football
s'ouvre aujourd'hui sur le fc versailles
78 le club est toujours en course en
coupe de france l'équipe sénior
pourraient évoluer en ligue 2 dans les
prochaines années ce sera notre module
découverte l'actualité sportive c'est
maintenant sur tb 78
mais avant de développer ces titres on
va parler un box ce sera peut-être l'un
des tournants de la carrière de tony
yoka le boxeur originaire de chanteloup
les vignes a annoncé qu'il acceptait la
proposition le combat formulées par le
croate philippe et hrgovic pour une demi
finale yb et f des lourds un sacré duel
en perspective les deux boxeurs sont
invaincus chez les professionnels ils se
sont déjà rencontrées en demi finale des
jeux olympiques de rio en 2016 à cette
époque le français l'avait emporté le
lieu et la date n'ont pas encore été
communiquées le vainqueur aura le droit
de disputer un combat contre l'ukrainien
musique détenteurs des titres des titres
unis wb aussi bfw aebea en football
américain les templiers à del en cours
ont débuté leur saison ce week-end
contre les dragons de paris une première
réussie puisque les élans courtois se
sont imposés avec la manière 18 à 0 des
images de patrick jacques de dixmude
deux ans qu'ils attendaient les joies
d'une victoire après deux saisons
blanches suite à la crise sanitaire les
templiers d'elancourt ont réussi leur
grand retour sur les terrains de
deuxième division avec une victoire face
aux dragons de paris ce samedi 15
janvier un match remporté avec la
manière ce qu'en finale 18 à 0 en vrai
y'a pas de match facile il ya des mois
tu maîtrises et c'est tout et là on a su
maîtriser avec un bon coaching staff des
bois no comment dire des bonnes
consignes et après derrière il ya une
bonne exécution a que comme ça qu'on
peut réussir de toute façon et a que
comme ça qu'on peut faire des clean
sheets
en gros on en a fait un ce soir et on
compte en faire d'autres je suis pas
surpris ça fait déjà un an et demi qu'on
s'entraîne ça fait un an et demi comme
ça sont hyper remontée et franchement ça
se voit sur tout le match l'équipe en
face n'a pas réussi à avancer c'est ce
qu'on voulait si le match s'est déroulé
dans la brume les objectifs du club sont
claires cette saison la montée pour
retrouver la première division
l'esprit coubertin où là on sait que
l'important c'est de participer mais on
veut aussi gagner en fait on fait ce
sport ça sport de compétition notre but
c'est d'aller en finale de passer ces
play-offs d'aller en finale l'objectif
c'est d'être invaincus l'objectif c'est
d'aller en finale l'objectif c'est de
gagner la finale et l'objectif forcément
ces montants nietzsche est temps qu'on
perd pas et c'est ce qu'on va faire et
maintenant qu'on peut repasser on va
aller en élite on va aller encore plus
loin le but c'est d'aller en élite c'est
de gagner l'élite c'est d'aller en
europe et c'est de gagner l'europe aussi
ça remettra dans un an deux ans trois
ans mon le fera pour confirmer leur bon
début de saison et continuer à rêver
d'une montée en fin d'année les
templiers d'elancourt se déplaceront ce
29 janvier sur le terrain des docks hers
ii lente
[Applaudissements]
on continue notre tour d'horizon des
résultats sportifs du week end dans le
département bixente merlan santisteva
nous a rejoint sur ce plateau bonsoir
bixente sans mickaël à la une
aujourd'hui arthur rinderknecht c'est
bon enfin enfin arthur indoor neige
entre dans le top 50 mondial 48e plus
exactement ce palier le tennisman saint
germanois la franchise grâce à sa belle
performance au tournoi d'adélaïde en
australie où il signe au passage aussi
sa première finale dans un tournoi atp
finals qu'il a perdu samedi face à de
son homologue australien thanassis
kokkalakis 7/6 6/7 3/6 c'est le
troisième français le mieux classé
derrière gaël monfils 20e et ugo humbert
40e et pas de repos pour lui il reste
sur l'australie et reluire c'est ça tout
juste le temps de se déplacer à 700
kilomètres de là au sud-est d'adélaïde
vers melbourne pour disputer l'open
d'australie on suivra d'ailleurs avec
attention son premier tour demain matin
il va falloir se lever aux aurores
michael à cette heure plus à 7h heure
française contre un autre australien
alexei paupérise 59e mondial je vais
peut-être mettre le réveil est un peu
plus tard et regarder la fin du match et
en lice par une victoire d'arthur inox
ne l'ouvrent l'autre page football à
présent et le versailles et versailles
et qui jouait en national de jouer on en
parlait récemment après leur
qualification historique en 8e de finale
de coupe de france youssef chibi
l'entraîneur versailles et avait annoncé
très clairement que l'objectif restait
le championnat de nationale 2 avec deux
échéances importantes avant le prochain
tour
la victoire était donc impérative ce
week-end face à
saint-pryvé-saint-hilaire et c'est chose
faite le score 3 buts à 1 ça avait mal
débuté avec la perte de l'attaquant
double buteur en coupe nationale
christopher iba est blessé au dos juste
avant la rencontre et savait encore plus
mal débuter puisque les versailles ont
encaissé un premier but à la 4ème minute
ils ont su rebondir et imposer leur jeu
avec trois buts aux 42e 63e et 75e
minute versa il prend la première place
de la division après le match nul de la
réserve de lorient à rouen dans la même
poule poissy se déplacer à granville un
match nul 2-2 pour les pisciacais la
huitième égalité en 15 journées qui
permet quand même de grappiller quelques
points sur la zone de relégation fois ci
est à cinq points du 14e premier
relégable en national 3 la division
inférieure la nationale 3 justement où
deux clubs divino elle joue lorraine
dans la division oui avec un troisième
match de suite sans défaite pour les
mureaux et un deuxième succès de rang
après la victoire 2 1 face à brétigny
quant aux montois fc 78 une défaite 1 0
sur la pelouse de l'équipe b du paris fc
pour rappel les mureaux et le mantois fc
78 joue pour ne pas descendre et sont
classés 9e et 10e sur 14 un petit mot de
basket à présent à bixente trappe
recevait caen ce samedi l'année 2022
commence bien pour les trappistes qui
après avoir l'avoir emporté la semaine
dernière contre le mans en chêne contre
l'union caen hérouville basket 81 à 75
trap est deuxième du championnat avec 10
victoires pour trois défaites et se
rendra ce week-end sur le parquet de
barjouville avant dernier du championnat
le club de marly le roi également
présents dans cette division 2 nationale
3 occupe la dernière place après une
défaite à bayeux dans l'actualité du
week-end aussi à monter saône et qui
finit le dakar jean pierre garcin qui
était parti avec son coéquipier lionel
baud au volant de leur peugeot 3008 dkr
sont arrivés à la 48ème position un peu
plus de 30 heures du premier c'est le
23e rallye dakar pour le co pilote
originaire de montesson rien que ça rien
que ça et on termine par du cross mais
les championnats départementaux de
cross-country se déroulait ce week-end à
la base de loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines plusieurs clubs ont performé le
gpso l'union athlétique de versailles ou
encore l'entente athlétique de sky on va
justement s'arrêter sur le club saint
quentinois plusieurs victoires en élite
femmes remporté par là et ici à
croissant en élite hommes avec cyril
vincent syrie en équipes les garçons ont
terminé premiers et troisièmes ils
avaient deux équipes et les filles 3e
également en élite enfin chez les
cadettes on l'a suivi michael récemment
jade le corps la grande promesse divine
was a bien entendu confirmé son statut
de favorite elles l'emportent devant une
autre coureur de la sky elisa croissant
sur le week-end 1397 athlètes venant de
tout le département étaient inscrits
lors de cet événement qui se voulait
également éco responsable merci à
bixente pour toutes ces précisions on
vous retrouve la semaine prochaine bien
sûr michael et en cyclisme ils ont
tourné pendant six heures au vélodrome
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines 23
équipes de trois à quatre coureurs se
sont relayés sur la piste lors d'une
compétition d'endurance le but parcourir
le plus de kilomètres possible un
reportage de patrick jacques de dixmude
et margot jésus
il ne fallait pas avoir le tournis
samedi 15 janvier au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
les coureurs cyclistes par équipes de
trois ou quatre ont parcouru la piste
durant pas moins de six heures ils
avaient tous un objectif en tête faire
le plus grand nombre de tours possible
en se relayant sur la piste faire un
relais d'une heure et demie c'est quand
même l'on essaie de faire d'eux de
relais quoi de trois quarts d'heure à
peu près pour essayer d'optimiser un peu
car le passage de relais c'est le moment
clé de la course il faut être très très
rapide dans le passage des relais
passage du transpondeur donc à son
équipier est généralement houpert de
tout revoir trois tours mais là on perd
on peut perdre facilement un ou deux
tours et on peut faire perdre la course
sur le passage des relais dans les 23
équipes de cette seconde édition il y
avait tous types des sportifs venus de
toute la france la particularité c'est
d'avoir des des champions des grands
champions aujourd'hui nous avons les
médailles olympiques et avec des abonnés
et des gens de toutes les catégories
parmi ces grands champions il y avait
notamment ceux de l'équipe de france
nous en tant que sprinteur ça nous
permet de faire des volumes nettement
plus important
de partager un moment convivial avec une
autre athlète
j remettre un dossard de ces baisses
mais venez imposition tous championnats
du monde qui avait eu lieu en octobre
dernier sur au batteur de ça sert les ir
et et rigoler avec les amis puisque jour
bonne ambiance donc j'aime bien faire ce
genre de choses après plus de 1000 70%
environ 260 km c'est l'équipe assurances
vélo qui a remporté la coupe elle était
composée de tom derache melvin
landerneau et baptiste et didier on va
maintenant ouvrir une page sport
automobile c'était il ya vingt ans le 15
janvier à 2002 l'équipe de formule 1
prost gp basé à guyancourt et mise en
liquidation judiciaire avec une dette de
35 millions d'euros coup de projecteur
sur cette écurie dirigé de 1997 à 2001
par alain prost et qui aura décroché
trois podiums à montage de rémi lefebvre
[Musique]
les pièces de la paix 02 100 par exemple
réalisé en ce moment dans l'atelier
derrière nous
vous êtes ici au contrôle de qualité
qu'est ce qu'on y fait on fait le
contrôle de toutes les pièces qui sont
montés sur la voiture c'est à dire ça va
de la petite rondelle en passant par les
boîtes de vitesses
[Musique]
on n'a pas de sécurité à tous les
niveaux
il n'est pas question de
défendre - touristes puisque financiers
qui soient morales
qu'ils soient
les à tous les niveaux l'arrivée des
grands constructeurs on en est un
avec les moyens sont complètement
disproportionnées c'est devenu un
championnat devançant sculpteur pour
trouver des financements d'espagne
s'est aussi beaucoup plus difficile la
situation économique n'est pas le fait
qu'ils aient eu pas mal de fusions
acquisitions dans les années passent et
non plus entre elles diminuent le nombre
[Musique]
ça commence avec des lots
comme les éléments de carrosserie qui
sont plutôt des souvenirs pour des
amateurs ou des passionnés de la formule
1 et 2 de l'écurie prost donc c'est des
éléments qui feront 500 euros enfin
entre 100 et 500 euros tout le monde
pourra y trouver une pièce un aileron un
triangle un élément personnel et
personnalisé proches
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on va maintenant parler à mercato
clément chantôme a quitté alès poissy
l'ancien parisien aujourd'hui âgé de 34
ans était arrivé au club pisciacais en
2020 pour aider le club en nationale 2
après deux saisons tronquées par
quelques blessures le joueur a décidé de
rejoindre chartres coachée par jean
pierre papin et qui évolue également en
nationale 2 fois ci touchera quelques
indemnités dans l'opération toujours en
nationale 2 de football tv 60,18 vous
propose aujourd'hui un coup de
projecteur sur le fc versailles 78 le
club est aujourd'hui en plein à
développement et pourrait intégrer la
ligue 2 dans léa prochaines années nous
sommes allés sur le terrain
d'entraînement pour rencontrer les
dirigeants coach et joueurs regardez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous l'aurez compris aujourd'hui on va
parler un football nous sommes sur les
terrains d'entraînement du fc versailles
à 78 les hommes de youssef schibbye sont
qualifiés pour les huitièmes de finale
de la coupe de france ils affronteront
toulouse et il vise également une montée
en fin de saison
mais côté le directeur général du club
jean luc arribart alors jean luc
arribart comment ça se passe depuis
votre arrivée au club c'était en
novembre dernier c'est ça début octobre
début octobre et octobre se passe très
bien puisque l'équipe et est en tête du
championnat
en coupe de france on est toujours en
course je peux pas arriver de meilleures
conditions de meilleures circonstances
pour démarrer on va revenir sur votre
situation personnelle pourquoi vous avez
voulu venir ici à versailles parce que
les actionnaires me l'ont demandé et que
j'ai accepté je trouve que c'est un
projet très excitant nous avons des
ambitions nous avons des moyens grâce à
eux et
genre j'aime j'aime à dire qu'on a des
ambitions raisonnables voilà on va faire
grandir le club on va le structurer et
voici et d'emmener l'équipe première
plus haut ça veut dire quoi des
ambitions raisonnables c'est vraiment le
faire grandir petit à petit bon déjà on
a l'impression que ça va trop vite non
parce que quand je dis ambitions
raisonnables je pense à tous ceux qui
crient haut et fort qu'ils vont aller
dans l'élite qui vont être dans les 50
meilleures équipes d'europe dans les dix
ans à venir et c'est non on n'a pas
cette cette arrogance là parce qu'on
connaît trop le football enfin en ce qui
me concerne j'ai un petit peu de
bouteille donc j'ai beaucoup d'humilité
c'est pas parce qu'on a beaucoup de
bonnes idées qu'on travaille bien qu'on
a des moyens
qu'on est sûr d'y arriver
on va essayer de bien faire les choses
mais on sait qu'en football c'est allé
il ya beaucoup de parallèles à thouars
donc on
va bosser on va s'organiser bien et on
espère que ça va que ça va fonctionner
mais on sait que ça peut mettre du temps
d'atteindre nos objectifs
on a envie d'aller dans le monde
professionnel donc dans un premier
première étape c'est d'aller vers la
ligue 2 d'avoir un centre de formation
voilà c'est tout ce qui nous anime
aujourd'hui c'est ce projet à moyen et
long terme quel est votre rôle à vous
quels sont les dossiers sur lesquels
vous travaillez au quotidien
allez je vous dire que du boulot à faire
ça je savais qu'un oreilles en acceptant
le poste mais j'imaginais pas fac et le
point c'est prenant d'autant que je
continue à commenter les matches pour
canal donc les vaches anglais donc ce
qu'on fait c'est d'abord
organiser une équipe autour de moi parce
que
il veut un vrai besoin de faire venir
des la compétence des gens à fond dans
notre projet et qui vont nous aider à
grandir aussi donc marc mohamed et
mickaël michel sont venus me rejoindre
et puis
les structures parce qu'on est sous
structure et par rapport à notre
situation sportive hainaut et nos
ambitions d'autant qu'on est en tête du
championnat si on a la réussite de
monter en national donc il faut qu'on
s'aide combler rapidement plus vite le
retard qu'on a au niveau des structures
donc on travaille sur les structures ont
travaillé en collaboration avec la
mairie qui a une écoute très
bienveillante et constructive avec nous
et donc on essaie d'avancer d'avancer
vite parce que le temps presse et on
voit là il ya beaucoup de sujets et des
sujets à plus long terme aussi oui un
petit souci sur sur le stade notamment
je le rappelle on ne peut pas avoir
d'éclairage la nuit au stade mon bon
alors parce qu'on ne peut pas voir une
lumière depuis la chambre du roi soleil
oui enfin c'est est un serpent de mer
enfin c'est quelque chose qui traîne
depuis plusieurs années il faut la
décision falloir d'aider des abf des
architectes des bâtiments de france
ça fait des années que ça dure
aujourd'hui on sait donc maintenant
qu'on pourra pas jouer à montbron la
saison prochaine on peut déjà pas joué
notre huitième de finale contre toulouse
chez nous et on veut à montbron ce qui
gâche évidemment déjà la fête vis-à-vis
de nos supporteurs et l'engouement que
ça avait généré les seizièmes donc on
est très déçus tsar évidemment on va
essayer de trouver des solutions on
travaille là dessus parce que on a deux
sites penche fontaine et membres auront
donc on est en train de voir comment on
peut en tirer le meilleur
ensuite la question on nous parle
souvent de et un stade est-ce que vous
allez cours sur un stade c'est une
hypothèse mais pour l'instant non on est
obligé de évidemment de 2,2 de fer avec
les structures existantes et on va
essayer
rapidement de nous mettre en conformité
avec le cahier des charges de la de la
fédé et la possibilité éventuelle de
jouer la prochaine en national et
j'imagine que vous travaillez également
en étroite collaboration avec youssef
chibi sur le mercato est ce que c'est un
sujet qui vous passionne aussi et qui
est important pour le club qui me
passionne c'est un bien grand mot c'est
important de 2,2 de mettre l'équipe dans
les meilleures conditions c'est
important de pas avoir de regrets à la
fin de saison donc c'est possible qu'on
se renforce de deux ou trois joueurs
parce qu'on a un effectif qui est pas si
important que ça quantitativement on et
21 puce trois gardiens c'est ça oui
c'est ça bon compte tenu des périodes
sanitaires très compliqué le coc vide
les blessures éventuelles les
suspensions il faut qu'on soit sans
doute un petit peu mieux armé pour finir
le championnat puis surtout pour pas
avoir de regrets on est trop bien placé
aujourd'hui pour jouer la montée ou en
tous les cas être dans la compétition
pour la montée avec trois quatre équipes
probablement
il faut jouer notre coup à fond parce
que c'est une chance d'être bien placé à
mi parcours mais c'est pas gagné donc on
sait que le plus dur reste à faire
continuer à rester plus longtemps
possible en tête et puis donc en
renforçant l'équipe on se dit que on
amènera des joueurs qui vont avoir
l'ambition de nous renforcer c'est ce
qu'on recherche évidemment est qui qui
doivent aussi s'intégrer dans dans un
vestiaire où il ya de la joie il ya déjà
une complicité qui s'est établie donc il
faut qu'ils s'intègrent par l'état
d'esprit par leur volonté de nous nous
rejoindre leurs qualités sur le terrain
la location vous l'avez évoqué un il y
aura ce huitième de finale contre
toulouse une équipe de ligue 2
comment où vous voyez ce match ce que ça
sera le petit poucet face aux gros ou
est ce que vous vous dites finalement
c'est peut-être jouable c'est jouable
évidemment pas déclaré forfait parce que
toulouse nous fait peur au point qu'on
n'a pas envie de les jouer non bien sûr
que bien sûr que c'est jouable mais
c'est un sacré challenge on va essayer
de le relever on va essayer de
poursuivre l'aventuré
est ce que vous risquez un petit
pronostic
moi je verrais bien un partout et on
passe aux tirs au but merci jean luc
arriva et on vous le souhaite merci bien
[Musique]
youssef chebbi l'entraîneur de l'équipe
première est à mes côtés alors youssef
chimiques comment se déroule cette
saison 2021 2022 plutôt bien puisque on
est sur une place très favorable pour
l'accession en n1 jusqu'à présent et on
est qualifié pour les huitièmes de
finale de coupe de france donc pour
l'instant les les feux sont au vert
c'est espérer ou pas cette seconde place
dans le championnat de nationale 2 pour
l'instant et ces 8e de finale contre
toulouse non ce serait présomptueux de
le penser on l'a on prépare toutes les
rencontres pour les remporter c'est
certain maintenant on restait malgré
tout à une équipe qui avait déserté les
championnats nationaux depuis une
vingtaine d'années donc on y revenez
avec beaucoup d'humilité donc ça se
passe plutôt bien avec un groupe qui
s'est renouvelé cet été donc une
cohésion qui qui prend plutôt bien
jusqu'à présent un parcours ben
parcourront
mon père forme pour l'instant on prend
les matches les uns après les autres
donc ça se passe bien vous êtes au club
depuis de nombreuses années vous avez vu
les nouveaux investisseurs qui sont
arrivés ici au club ces derniers mois
comment vous vivez cette situation vous
bah moi je suis spectateur et acteur jeu
je suis un salarié du club jusqu'à
présent depuis quelques années et c'est
positif parce que c'était espéré depuis
un certain temps pour pouvoir poursuivre
le projet qui a été
impulsée depuis quelques saisons
maintenant il était nécessaire pour
pouvoir rivaliser avec les équipes de la
division mais d'apporter un souffle
nouveau que ce soit au niveau des moyens
humains et les moyens financiers quel
est votre style de jeu il cette chipie
vous êtes plutôt un entraîneur défensif
offensif
bon moi je suis un peu les deux vous
avez honte dans un match on a des
aspects qu'on doit gérer défensivement
et offensivement donc il faut la
recherche permanente d'un équilibre donc
faire en sorte d'être bien évidemment
solide dans l'animation défensive que
tous les joueurs soient concernés par le
travail défensif et après offensivement
bien sûr avoir des possibilités
des multiples possibilités pour pouvoir
mettre l'adversaire en difficulté
vous préférez quoi que votre équipe joue
bien ou remporter la victoire
vous savez on peut pas avoir une saison
linéaire manière générale on a des
périodes où on est bien
on doit s'adapter aussi aux éléments les
périodes hivernales notamment
après on sera toujours
on est toujours au but les par le
résultat quoi qu'il arrive et tout ce
qu'on entreprend sur le terrain est
guidé par l'envié de marquer des buts et
celle de remporter les matches et malgré
les faux les moments où parfois on peut
être un peu moins bien dans le jeu si on
réussit à préserver résultat c'est
l'essentiel mais bien évidemment que
qu'un esprit de jeu une philosophie de
jeu des principes à respecter font que
nous devrons beaucoup plus dans dans
dans la compétition et dans la
performance donc c'est pour ça que c'est
aussi un équilibre à trouver vous avez
les jours qui vous correspond peut-être
à votre style de jeu où les chercher ses
joueurs oui bah je perds depuis quelques
saisons de cette liberté à versailles de
pouvoir
choisir les joueurs que je souhaite
c'était encore le cas cet été donc bien
sûr je suis un exercice important
essentiel dans la réussite d'une saison
même si on peut pas réussir
complètement dans les recrues et dans
les profils con qu'on souhaite mais ça
se passe plutôt bien et tous les joueurs
qui ont été choisis depuis des années et
encore plus cette saison c'est des
joueurs qui ont été observées qui on a
pris du temps avec qui on a discuté
échangé pour aussi s'assurer d'un état
d'esprit qui à mes yeux est essentielle
je suis maintenant avec deux joueurs de
versailles itza et lido vic alors enza
pour comment se déroule cette saison
2021 2022 pour toi ici à versailles a
plutôt pas mal hein on a bien commencé
l'année à passer pas fini la saison
n'est qu'à la moitié il faut continuer
faut redoubler d'efforts et faire encore
mieux pour la deuxième partie est ce que
tu prends du plaisir et ici à versailles
oui oui oui déjà là bas je viens de la
région parisienne du coup la ceinture
autour pour moi et franchement je prends
du plaisir sur le terrain et en dehors
je pense que ça se voit
ludovic même chose pour toi tu prends
beaucoup de plaisir ici a évolué à
versailles oui franchement plutôt
surpris en arrivant ici je m'attendais
pas mais en fait tout se passe bien le
croupier il est bon en temps tous bien
donc les résultats suivent aussi dont on
on ne compte en
partie de saison impeccable de france a
encore qualifié championnat ça se passe
bien donc il faut continuer à travailler
est ce qu'on peut dire c'est une
première partie de saison quasi parfaite
qu'a réalisé versailles casino on a
perdu un match mais
c'est une bonne saison mais le
championnat il est il est très long donc
il faut pas s'arrêter là et continue à
travailler en fait partie comme une des
meilleures équipes du championnat on est
d'accord oui pour l'instant oui mais par
expérience avec ça va très vite donc il
faut vraiment continuer à bosser on peut
être en haut à la marche et la saison et
puis finir 10e 1 d importer donc il faut
faut être sérieux quand on a travaillé
comme ont fait depuis le début tout le
monde en parle de ce match contre
toulouse ce match de coupe de france il
a toi comment tu le ressens ce match de
coupe de france à ce que tu es déjà
focalisé là-dessus où on prend les
matches les uns après les autres noms on
prend les matches les uns après les
autres on sait que c'est à la fin du
mois c'est le 29 ou 30 janvier du coup
nous reste encore on a des matches de
championnat avant et il faut qu'on soit
focus déjà sur le championnat la coupe
c'est vraiment en bonus la déjà arrivé
déjà en 8e de finale c'est déjà un beau
parcours
on rencontre une ligue 2 du coup c'est
très bien pour nous pour le club pour
nos familles pour pour l'ensemble on
ensemble mais en tout cas l'essentiel
c'est le championnat la coupe c'est
vraiment du bonus comptant ce tirage
face à toulouse on aurait préféré une
ligue 1 c'est à dire paris marseille un
gros gros gros mais il faut pas négliger
toulouse c'est quand même une grosse
équipe c'est quand même un club pro et
surtout ils sont pas mal en ligue 2 ils
sont il marche un peu sur l'eau du coup
avec une grosse attaque du coup
devra faire attention vous êtes milieu
défensif il faudra arrêter tous les
ballons c'est ça oui c'est ça sale
boulot seul joueur
des mets bon
vu que même chose ça sera un gros match
ce match contre toulouse quand elle
cynique 200 enfin taro match apporte une
moment c'est un club pro donc ça fait un
gros match peu importe l'équipe ligue 2
ligue 1 nous on est content donc sa
tenue ça va être une fête pour tout le
monde et même si la priorité reste le
championnat
on va prendre ça comme ça vient on est
là pour s'amuser c'est pour les joueurs
vous l'aurez compris le sait versailles
78 a de grandes ambitions pour léa
prochaines années le prochain rendez
vous ce sera contre toulouse ce huitième
de finale de coupe de france
c'est la fin de cette émission merci
l'avoir suivi à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]